Python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges vital never ceases to
surprise its audience most day
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of Python every day
hi I'm a picture from simply on and well
after some thought in a bit more
research I was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top Python libraries
for data science
what are they let's find out so let's
talk about this amazing library
tensorflow
which is also one of my favorites so
tensorflow is a library for
high-performance numerical computations
with around 35,000 github commits and a
vibrant community of around 1,500
contributors and it's used across
various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can say
I partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tens of flow so tensor flow is
majorly used in deep learning models and
neural networks where we have other
libraries like torsion theano also but
tensor flow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensor flow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in noodle machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where can
train multiple neural networks and
multiple GPUs for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel computing
feature of pens flow is also called
pipelining also tensor flow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by Google
it has quicker updates frequent new
releases with the latest of features now
let's look at some applications tensor
flow is extensively used in speech and
image recognition text based
applications time series analysis and
forecasting and various other
applications involving video detection
so favorite thing about tensor flow that
it's already popular among the machine
learning community and most are open to
trying it and some of us are already
using it now let's look at an example of
a tensor flow model in this example we
will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we're using amnestied asset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple tensor
flow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using MATLAB library
the inputs will look something like this
then we create a tensor flow model to
create a basic tensor flow model we need
to initialize the variables and start a
session then after training the model we
can validate the data and then predict
the accuracy this model has predicted
92% accuracy let's see which is pretty
well for this model so that's all for
tensor flow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
Python library called numpy numba is a
fundamental package for numerical
computation in Python it stands for
numerical Python as the name suggests it
has around 18,000 commits on github
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general-purpose
array processing packaged in a way that
it provides high-performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number it's very easy to
work with large arrays and mattresses
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to end the array once again it's a
class possessing numerous methods and
attributes nd array provides for larger
and repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods I
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
signs it helps in creating the powerful
n dimensional array whenever we talk
about numpy dimension of the array we
can
do it without the mention of the
powerful in dimension array also number
is extensively used in machine learning
when we are creating machine learning
models
Azen where it forms the base of other
libraries like psy by scikit-learn etc
when you start creating the machine
learning models in data science you will
realize that all the models will have
their bases numpy or pandas also when
numba is used with sci-fi and matplotlib
it can be used as a replacement of
MATLAB now let's look at a simple
example of an array in Nampa as you can
see here there are multiple array
manipulation routines like their basic
examples where you can copy the values
from one area to another we can give a
new shape to an array from maybe one
dimensional to we can make it as a two
dimensional array we can return a copy
of the array collapse into one dimension
now let's look at an example where this
is a jobber notebook
and we will just create a basic array
and for detailed explanation you can
watch our other videos which targets on
these explanations of each libraries so
first of all whenever we are using any
library in Python we have to import it
so now this NP is the alias which we
will be using let's create a simple
array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an Indian a type of are you
also let's look what's the shape of
disarray
so this is a shape of the ADI now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
this is where you can change the shape
of theory using all those functions now
let's create an order using arrange
functions if I give arranged 12 it will
give me a 1d array of 12 numbers like
this now we can reshape this array
two three comma four all we can write it
here itself
so this is how arranged function and the
reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next library which is
Sai PI so this is another free and open
source Python library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this library as the name
suggests and for scientific python and
it has around 19,000 commits on github
with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations
now let's discuss about some features of
Syfy so Syfy has a collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of faith secondly
it has various high-level commands for
data manipulation and visualization also
the end EMH function of Syfy is very
useful in multi-dimensional image
processing and it includes built-in
functions for solving differential
equations linear algebra and many more
so that was about the features of Syfy
now let's discuss its applications so
Syfy is used in multi dimensional image
operations it has functions to read
images from disk into number arrays to
write arrays to discuss images resize
images etc solving differential
equations Fourier transforms then
optimization algorithms linear algebra
etc let's look at a simple example to
learn what kind of functions are there
inside by here I'm importing the
constants package of scipy library so in
this package it has all the constants so
here I'm just mentioning C or H or any
and this library already knows what it
has to fetch like speed of light
Planck's constant etc so this can be
used in further calculations these
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munging
and then cleaning the data also hence
mention of pandas is a must in data
science lifecycle yes pandas is the most
popular and widely used Python library
for data science along with numpy in
matplotlib the name itself stands for
Python data analysis with around 17,000
commits on github and an active
community of 1,200 contributors it is
heavy
used for data analysis and cleaning as
it provides fast flexible data
structures like data frames CDs which
are designed to work with structured
data very easily and intuitively now
let's talk about some features of pandas
so panas offers this eloquent syntax and
rich functionalities there are various
methods and panels like drop any fail
any which gives you the freedom to deal
with missing data also Manas provides a
powerful apply function which lets you
create your own function and run it
across a series of data now forget about
writing those for loops when using
panels also this libraries high-level
abstraction over low-level numpy which
is written in pure C then it also
contains these high-level data
structures and manipulation tools which
makes it very easy to work with pandas
like their data structures and series
now let's discuss the applications of
pandas so panas is extensively used in
general data wrangling in data cleaning
then pandas also finds its usage in ETL
jobs for data transformation and data
storage as it has excellent support for
loading CSV files into its data frame
format then pandas is used in a variety
of academic and commercial domains
including statistics finance
neuroscience kana makes web analytics
cetera then pandas is also very useful
in time series specific functionality
like date range generation moving window
linear regression date shifting etc now
let's look at a very simple example of
how to create data frame so data frame
is a very useful data structure in
pandas and it has very powerful
functionalities so here are only in
listing important libraries in data
science you can explore more of our
videos to learn about these libraries in
detail so let's just go ahead and create
data frame I'm using Jupiter notebook
again and in this before using pandas
here I'm importing the pandas library I
can go and run this so in data frame we
can import a file a CSV file Excel files
there are many functions doing these
things and we can also create our own
data and put it into data frame so here
I am taking random data and putting in a
data frame also I am creating an index
and then also giving the column names so
PD is the alias of given for Ponder's
random data of six by four index which
is taking arranged six numbers and
column name I'm giving us a b c d now
let's go ahead and look at it so you're
it has created a data frame with my
column names are ABCD my list as six
numbers zero to five and a random data
of six by four so data frame is just
another table with rows and columns
where you can do various functions over
it all so i can go ahead and describe
this data frame to see so it's giving me
all these functionalities where count
and mean and standard deviation etc okay
so that was about pandas now let's talk
about the next library and last one
Samad plot left for me is the most fun
library or all of them why because it
has such powerful yet beautiful
visualizations we see in the coming
slides plot in madrid lip suggests that
it's a plotting library for python it
has around 26,000 comets on github and a
very vibrant community of 700
contributors and because of such graphs
and plots that it produces it's majorly
used for data visualization and also
because it provides an object-oriented
api which can be used to embed those
plots into our applications let's talk
about the features of matplotlib the
pipe lot module of Matt Bradley provides
MATLAB like interface so matplotlib is
designed to be as usable as matlab with
an advantage of being free and open
source also it supports dozens of
backends and output types which means
you can use it regardless of which
operating system you're using or which
output format you wish - itself can be
used as wrappers around Madrid lips API
so as to drive Madrid live a cleaner and
more modern API is also when you start
using this library you will realize that
it has a very little memory consumption
and a very good runtime behavior now
let's talk about the applications of
matplotlib it's a modern term discover
the unknown relationship between the
variables in your data set so this
library helps to visualize the
correlation analysis of variables also
in machine learning we can visualize 95%
confidence interval of
model just to communicate how well our
model fits the data then Matt Varla
finds its application in outlier
detection using scatter plot etc and to
visualize the distribution of data to
gain instant insights now let's make a
very simple plot to get a basic idea
I've already imported the libraries here
so this function matplotlib in line will
help you show the plots in the jupiter
notebook this is also called a magic
function I won't be able to display my
plots in the jupiter notebook if I don't
use this function I'm using this
function in numpy to fix random state
for reproducibility now I'll take my n
as 30 and we'll assign random values to
my variables so this function is
generating 30 random numbers here I'm
trying to create a scatter plot so I
want to decide the area let's put this
so this is multiplying 30 with random
numbers to the power two so that we get
the area of the plot which we will see
in just a minute so using the scatter
function and the alias of my plot Lepus
PLD have created this if I don't use
this and have very small circles as my
scatter plot it's colorful it's nice so
that's one very easy plot I suggest that
you explore more of matplotlib and I'm
sure you will enjoy it let's create a
histogram so I'm using my stylus ggplot
and assigning some values to these
variables any random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work upon them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading Python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like tensor
flow chaos is another popular library
which is extensively used for deep
learning and neural network modules get
uh straps both tensorflow
and Theano back ends so it is a good
option if you don't want to dive into
details of tensor flow then scikit-learn
is a machine learning library it
provides almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
Syfy then we have Seabourn which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that c1 is an enhancement of
matplotlib as it introduces additional
blood types so this was about the top
Python libraries for data science
according to me it still may not cover
some other great useful libraries that
deserve to be looked at so share your
favorites in the comment section below
as well as any interesting things about
the libraries that we mentioned that's
all from my side thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here